okay today I'm going to talk to you
about moles now miles are something that
always confuses people in chemistry so
it's really important to remember this
key key concept so a mole is a certain
number of particles so all it is is a
certain number now that particular
number is given to us it's called
Avogadro's constant and that number is
this right here it's an enormous number
it's 6.02 times 10 to the 23 now the
reason why we write it in standard form
it's because it's so big this is how
it's written out in normal form so it's
just a number a number of particles so
if I had a mole of something it'd mean
I'd have this number of something a
little bit like saying if I've got a
dozen eggs it means I've got twelve eggs
if I've got a mole number of eggs for
example I'd have this many eggs okay
so that's the really important thing to
remember now what is the point now where
does this number come from
what is its relevance so let me explain
now the whole reason why I regard Rose
constant exists and why a mole why we
use moles is because of this whenever we
have one mole of anything it means that
its mass the mass of that substance
equals the either the relative atomic
mass or the relative formula mass of
that substance depending on what we're
talking about so its mass is equal to
those things so let me just show you an
example so for example let's think about
carbon selects imagine if I had one mole
of carbon what essentially that means if
I have that many atoms of carbon so to
find out the mass of that what I need to
do is I need to find carbon on the
periodic table so here it is right here
so carbon looks like this so if I have
one mole of carbon what I'm saying
is it's atomic mass relative atomic mass
is 12 so because it's relative atomic
mass is 12 that must also mean that its
mass is 12 grams so if I have that many
carbon atoms its mass of one mole of
carbon atoms
it weighs 12 grams because it's the same
as the relative atomic mass but this
also works with molecules so for example
if I had nitrogen first thing I need to
do is figure out what is this the
formula for nitrogen one nitrogen is M 2
it's nitrogen gas so they go around in
pairs they're a diatomic so what I need
to do this time to find out the relative
formula mass rather than just the atomic
mass so first of all again I go over to
my purity table so nitrogen is this 14-7
so the relative atomic mass of nitrogen
is 14 so the relative formula mass
because they go around in pairs is going
to be 14 times 2 which is 28 so
therefore if I have one mole of nitrogen
gas it is going to weigh 28 grams let's
do one more example so let's imagine if
I had a compound like carbon dioxide so
I know carbon dioxide is co2 so I'm
gonna see how much what would my mass be
if I had 1 mole of carbon dioxide so
again I've already know carbon from this
one here so I know that its mass number
is 12 oxygen and use my periodic table
to find oxygen here it is right here so
no oxygen its mass number is 16 so my
relative formula mass for oxygen is this
which is 44 therefore one mole of carbon
dioxide must weigh so it must one must
have a
of 44 grams okay so let's just see a
particular kind of question we could be
answered about this so a question says
how many atoms are there in five moles
of nitrogen gas how many atoms are there
in five moles of nitrogen gas okay so
what I'm gonna do first of all is I need
to just quickly think about what is my
formula for nitrogen so I know nitrogen
is n2 so say how many atoms are there in
five moles of nitrogen gas so all I need
to do first of all is think what is my
avocado cult constant so that is 6.02
times 10 to the 23 because remember that
is the number that means one mole so
what I need to do first of all is I need
to multiply this by five because that's
just one mole it's asking me for five
moles so what I need to do is 6.02 times
10 to the 23 and then take that answer
and multiply it by five which gives me
three point zero one times 10 to the 24
now it's fine to leave your answer in
standard form like this for now okay so
that's what I've done there is worked
out how many moles there are sorry how
many molecules there are in five moles
of nitrogen however because nitrogen is
diatomic there's two atoms in each
molecule of nitrogen I then need to take
my answer so three point zero two times
10 to the 24 and multiply that by two so
it times that by two which is six point
zero 2 times 10 to the 24 so just as a
recap what a mole is all that it means
is a certain number of particles this
number right here Avogadro's constant
this enormous number so the relevance of
this number remember is one mole of any
substance means its mass is the same is
the same as its relative atomic mass
thank you